[Music]
all right let's talk about
politics yay yay
you're excited i love politics because
like when people watch politics to go
oh no our future and then for me i'm
like
let's watch let's get ready to rumble
it's [ __ ] fake ass [ __ ] wwe time
yeah it is like wwe
think as [ __ ] the fakest [ __ ] ever it
feels like sports now
like like the political world it's like
it's just like
your team versus my team and then [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you yo but did you see
how like
trump wanted joe rogan oh yeah oh we're
gonna talk about that
yeah we're gonna talk about that but not
not this much yeah that's why i don't
like sports
or politics because i don't like that
divisiveness
you're like can we all just be friends
what about game of thrones
divisiveness can we be one big football
team
that doesn't play anyone we are we are
the corporatists are in control don't
even worry yeah don't worry about that
yeah
you all handle your [ __ ] i'm out that's
it that's how i
i see sports of politics that's more fun
though
it's like playing sports where the not
with the scores never
go up or down it just stays at zero the
entire time
all right so we're talking about uh
politics in cheshire county new
hampshire
heard about this story shit's hilarious
what happened
uh a satanist anarchist ran for
office as a republican but he didn't run
as a satanist anarchist he just ran
sorry trans satanist anarchist
and one and all the republicans are
[ __ ] pissed because they didn't know
she was a satanist trans anarchist how
does she run holy sh
just as a republican just like first of
a sheriff republican
yeah for the role of a sheriff don't you
have to be a [ __ ] like a deputy to be a
sheriff doesn't charity have to be a
police officer already
i don't know wait what are they mad
about so this is proof that
people just vote for the name that
they've seen the most on signs and stuff
and they don't give a [ __ ] to look into
the candidate and that's what she
basically is saying she was like the
fact that i can stroll in here
put my name on a ballot and then you
guys actually voted me in as a sheriff
and then she was like
do you not realize that i am not fit for
the role and then
her whole point of this thing i don't
know if it's a publicity stunt or not
like it is i don't think she intended
for her to win right
but then her whole point is the system
is broken clear
the best point ever so we have
luciferians are like we have actual
satanists right
there there are other troll satanists
yes
who basically challenge our government
system and
she might be coming from that camp
clearly they're not actual satanists
they're more like
atheists and logical peoples and what
they do is they use it
as a way to kind of point out the
hypocrisy so one example is like we're
trying to separate church from state
right and we'll have this huge statue of
like jesus or whatever maybe in the
bible belt
so the the the fake church of satan they
created a huge goat statue from the
devil and
donated that to i think so yeah
it was like a big goat like with the
[ __ ] staff and [ __ ] just sitting down
and they donated that to the city
government and said put that there too
it's a religious belief controversy
because literally
their whole political thing is about
like going into it
and calling out all the [ __ ] right
and then saying like
it isn't freedom of religion because
there's one religion that you guys don't
like
and then they're just using it as a way
to scare them they all short circuit and
[ __ ] because they're like we don't know
how to think outside of this so
which is pretty interesting yeah like in
the spaghetti monster
and stuff like that spaghetti monster's
awesome he's the best dude cthulhu is
great
what's kanye's again i forgot his
connie's yeah like the one
birthday party birthday party yeah what
if new hampshire is just so
open-minded where he's like or she's
like um see
i'm not fit for this and they're like
yeah you are everyone's fit for this job
let's just give it a try
that'll be amazing yeah that's quite a
counter troll yeah yeah double that
awesome video uh there's there i have a
video of her talking but she doesn't
really make a
a stance on what this article is do you
want to know what the response is though
if it's not that
like what is the result oh people are
pissed people people don't want her
uh don't want her to be a sheriff and
her whole campaign
i don't know how this slipped by
everyone the whole campaign slogan was
[ __ ] the police
oh my god complete troll
night masterful i'm running for sheriff
[ __ ] the police
and people were like her and her the
name on the ballot was arya de meza
that's her name so you just put the r
next to your name or the d next to your
name and everyone who likes them are
going to vote for you that's the that's
the game
wow if it's a lot of republicans in that
county
then they're just going to vote for the
republican of course so there's no
competing republican
yeah no so she did it even she said she
was expecting to lose the write-in
candidate you know the person that was
expected to win
but surprisingly she got all the votes
do we have a picture of the other
sheriff like it's
due with like all these medals and [ __ ]
i know
wait so who okay i want to know her
campaign
and why was it so successful yeah i
don't know what gloss goes on her
campaign website okay let's pull up her
campaign i just want to know how she won
if they can dissect that
yeah there's the yeah all right arya de
mezzo
for sheriff [ __ ] the police that's crazy
so she's not an actual republican she
just registered
and went through the process yeah toward
anarchy what a [ __ ] troll dude what's
crazy is
um that because like you know at least
in california you have to have been
a deputy before you become sheriff
mm-hmm
so for them like you you don't even have
to be a police officer to become a
sheriff that's crazy seems like it's a
very small town or like a small
county you know it doesn't it's
definitely not comparable to l.a
new hampshire and that's crazy to me too
because even though we have 50 states
it almost feels like some and we're
supposed to be first
world i guess but it feels like some
states are like underdeveloped countries
within the 50 states right right well
they don't they don't have funding right
so like a lot of
um counties in the east coast they like
so my stepdad was a volunteer fireman
yeah like california has a [ __ ] ton of
money yeah so
like we have some of the greatest like
highest paid
you know county workers like i think new
york is number one and
uh california's number two they pay
their mayor a million dollars in new
york
oh my god well i mean it makes sense
because of how much like
tax revenue it's bringing in or whatever
whatever but i don't know bro
i don't know if it's justified i'm just
saying that's more than the president
then right yeah
yeah exactly that's what people are like
he makes 100k right
500. yeah 400 500 yeah
foreign yeah but the thing
is a lot of uh counties in the east
coast um and maybe
all over america they rely on volunteer
policing sometimes like we had a friend
who was a part-time
um volunteer police for
some of the towns in new mexico because
uh
they just didn't have enough personnel
so
you can be an out-of-state dude who just
goes in
and and you volunteer for that town and
you got a uniform with barely any
training and you could patrol around
town
oh my god same with uh fire volunteer
firemen like you know
you're not really getting paid for it
but that doesn't scare me as much
well yeah because you're you don't you
don't have a gun but then the thing is
the services
these counties don't have enough for and
they have to rely like that's why i
think politicians and whatever like
no one wants that extra work and even
here
we don't really have full-time um
cabinet like council members
like they all have their nine-to-five
jobs even in the city
in l.a they have their nine-to-five jobs
and then on the side
they're part-timers but like downtown
delayed like
they're career politicians so but if you
think about a city like
monterey park or like san gabriel or
whatever
you would think that we have full-time
people in
office but you don't it's like the other
guys where he works at bed bath and
beyond and you're like
oh hey mayor can you help me with the
rug yeah that's what blows my [ __ ]
mind
i don't know if i want it i like that i
don't know if i want it i don't know if
i want these guys
there nine to five doing whatever the
[ __ ] they do because i don't think that
they do anything for us
i just think that's true given their
their little time there they're already
not doing anything no and the guys who
are there for
50 years 35 years all that [ __ ] don't do
anything for us either
like that if i guess like i don't know
we have 50 states everyone has their own
counties everything gets divided smaller
smaller and smaller so
but like you can't like the places that
have a [ __ ] ton more like
over like over budget
wait that doesn't matter there's no such
thing as over budget in in the
government and the reason why it's like
this so even in the military right
we for this amount of training we
allotted this much ammunition
and if we only use half guess what we
spend the next
like two hours just going through all
the ammunition
even though all of the training is over
because if we don't use it the next time
we apply for budgets we're not going to
get that
so so that's why they never know what if
you're not using it then why can't it go
to the people that do need it because
you're not gonna get it so this is how
it works out that's what that's the part
that sucks there's federal money
that a lot of the states can get help
from
but the states don't typically give to
each other
because it's almost like little
countries that
govern and run themselves and then we
have the federal who's kind of like the
eu who just like puts everybody together
but they can ask the federal government
for
relief and funding but i'm not too sure
if states give to each other in that
sense like maybe charity wise i don't
know
because we might get water rights to a
state and buy and
do trade but then we're not really like
we don't work that way where federal
government is so strong that they can
force one state to give to another state
because they need the help
yeah they're not really united we are
but
it's like independence for states that's
united by the federal government
yeah true like brothers and sisters that
hate each other you have to eat dinner
together
but then the irony too though is like
say you live in california and you're a
republican say
well a lot of your tax dollars are
coming from democrats
and you know if you're a farmer or
something you're benefiting from them
but then you hate them at the same time
so it's [ __ ] hilarious
that's why they try to divide up
california you remember that they were
like
northern california southern california
because the needs of like
central california is not the same of
like silicon valley
and that everyone is all going after
the same fund but it's not fair for like
the the farmers versus like the
hollywood peoples and whatever
that makes sense yeah just just to give
you an idea at how successful
arya was at uh she got 4
211 votes beating her opponents
uh in the gop who managed to only gather
a few hundred votes oh
god knock on those doors the satanist
was knocking on doors trolls yeah
i don't want to know the works that her
campaign is a grassroots campaign that's
all they say okay they said
they're a grassroots yeah it doesn't say
how she managed to get all the votes
like that
ran a successful grassroots campaign
that's all i say every time what if she
um just did it on facebook and people
didn't even know what she looked like
i think so because they did say that she
never showed up to any of the gop
meetings and events despite being
invited so she never
showed up in person ever so all the
people going are just like these people
suck
i'll wait and then they see another name
like [ __ ] it yeah better than all the
other names i know about
yourself sure oh it sounds refreshing
yeah we saw the way that uh they run
politics on the local level so for
example we
when we donated gopher broke to the
gopher broke education center
we had a press conference with a lot of
the local cities
and council members and when they came
in they basically
interviewed some of us and then they
just remembered everything
and then they came up with their speech
like immediately
and they all just went one after the
other giving their two cents about
like we're cool and what the the go for
broke people are about and all that
and i was like wow there's a whole
system behind all of this and like with
the reporters
what they ask there's kind of like i
feel like there's a whole set way
of how they conduct themselves how they
memorize information
how they talk to the community and it's
just this working thing that's been
going on
so when someone that isn't a part of
that group comes along and just talks
like a normal person
that's why we're seeing all this like
different [ __ ] going on yeah refreshing
like
lemonade so yeah so she is now the
republican candidate for the sheriff
position and she's up against eli rivera
who has done served five terms already
as sheriff so he's heavily popular so it
seems like the republicans are like
we don't want a democratic sheriff we
want a republican sheriff
no no this this is still oh so that was
the primary
that was the primary yeah but she is a
republican but she's
she's a republican on on the ballot i
want to be a sheriff
[Music]
you